everybody
to this virtual meeting of the annual
council
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use the
messaging chat function
during the meeting unless unless it is
to report a pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest or to notify
the chair
that you wish to make a proposal that if
you are attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you'll
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair please
await your turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting that they
they must contact the member support
officer mandy smith
as soon as possible as this is a virtual
meeting
you will not need to stand to address
the chair
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting
you are also consenting to being filmed
by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public
and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
we'll now proceed to the meeting
as i may be nominated for the position
of chairman
i will now hand over to the vice
chairman
and leave the meeting for item one on
the agenda
so um adrian osborne would you take over
please
thank you catherine can i move to the
agenda please which
is item one election of chairman of the
council
please can i have nominations for the
position of chairman
thank you councillor osborne i'd like to
make a proposal
i'd like to propose that catherine
grandin continue as our chairman of
council
she's had an excellent first nine months
um both in the council chamber and
performing
her various civic and ceremonial duties
which is carried off with a balance of
gravitas elegance
and some panache the last seven months
have been a challenge for us all but
catherine has adapted to
a new way of working and i think we all
appreciate her
efforts to make meetings such as this
run as smoothly as possible
i propose catherine grandin as chairman
of baby district council
thank you councillor arthi can i have a
second it please
i'd like to second
can you hear me vice chairman sue isn't
it
it's sue carpenter got my hand up
i see that thank you sir i i'm very
happy to second this nomination
and as clive says over many months
particularly during current
circumstances
councillor grandin has shown skill and
composure
steering us through our agenda
it's a pity that the civic element of
her role
has been curtailed because of the
coronavirus
but maybe there'll still be an
opportunity for her to fulfill that duty
in which she excels i'm sure council
will be very pleased
to support her nomination thank you
thank you sue are there any
other further nominations
no right so i shall now
ask the corporate manager governance and
civic office to take the roll call vote
please
thank you vice chair um if i can ask
members to reply with
um for or abstain
for um the vote please
um councillor arfy four
cancer heirs four councillor barrett
four councillor beer
councillor busby four councillor
carpendale
four councillor creswell
i don't think he's present cancer davis
paul councillor dawson christine
councillor fraser four
cancer gould sorry she's not here
councillor
granger howard or cancer
grandin oh no cancer heartache
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lindsay four councillor malveezy
or councillor mayberry four
councillor mccraw four councilmember
karen
for councillor newman four
cancer norman four councillor nunn
four cancer osborne
four councillor jan osborne
for cancer owen paul
councillor parker paul councillor plum
for council award war
thank you vice chair that is carried
thank you very much unanimously i
declare
council grand and julie elected
[Music]
um yes
um
we're just waiting for councillor
grandin to rejoin the meeting thank you
congratulations catherine glad to see
you back oh
thank you very much thank you
um thank you thank you everyone i better
sign the book then i actually have the
book here
so let's find out
so i'll just do the formalities thank
you everybody
i catherine grandin having been elected
to the office of chairman of the council
hereby declare that i take that office
upon myself and will duly and
faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
i undertake to be guided by the suffolk
local code of conduct
in the performance of my functions in
that office
now if i may i'd like to say a few words
thank you for your indulgence
first i would like to thank clive arthy
for proposing me
and sue carpendale for seconding me for
the second term
as chairman of baba district council
i also thank my fellow councillors for
supporting me
not just now in the vote but also since
may 2019
in particular i would like to give my
thanks to vice chairman adrian osborne
for his support for the past year and a
half
sometimes being asked to stand in for me
at short notice
and always offering to do whatever he
can to be of assistance
of course this does sometimes come with
updates on how england are doing in the
cricket
but cricket scores aside it is always
great to know
that adrian's smiling enthusiasm for all
things
to do with the council are there when i
need some help
and thank you also to the democratic
services
and civic office teams for all the work
they have done to support my role
it is often work that is not seen but is
vital in helping the chairman's role to
run smoothly
i'm truly honoured to be selected for a
second term as chairman
as we all know these are and i hesitate
to use the word that we hear so often
now
unprecedented times
when we were all elected in may 2019 who
would have thought
that a year later we would be in
lockdown
may 2019 was such a different world
organizing the count following the
election will be an interesting prospect
now
and the annual meeting 2019
certainly looks markedly different from
this annual meeting
2020 parts of my acceptance speech at
that
at the start of my first term perhaps
struck a lighter note
in keeping with those times with
references to my keenness for dressing
up
and my hopes for fundraising events
my first year has been a year of two
halves as they say
i've been proud to represent baber
district council at so many interesting
events
i tended such occasions with relish and
took my civic duties very seriously
hadley the town i represent has clearly
enjoyed the fact that i've been given
the honor of caring the council
and invited me to open hadley on show
amongst other events
oh and while i'm saying my thank yous at
the beginning
i should not forget to mention my
husband roger who accompan
accompanied me to numerous events and
being
became accustomed to chauffeur and
console duties
the second half of my term of course is
rather a contrast
along with all other events my planned
fundraising chairman's charity ball
had to be cancelled the ball gown bought
prematurely
is hanging in the wardrobe
but while the crisis of the pandemic has
seen many special events cancelled
and more importantly in some cases in
loss of life and livelihood
there have also been times of optimism
doing things differently
and we can be proud of our council and
communities
pulling together showing empathy
working hard and extending a helping
hand
to those in need i was asked which
clarity i plan to support in this my
second term
i regret that i have not been able to
give as much as i would have liked to my
chosen charity
hadley dementia action alliance last
year
the ball was intended to do that in a
big way
two local companies and a private
individual
generously gave donation for my
charities
i added happy guides and scouts while
planning the ball
but of course without the ball those
kind donations were
all i have been able to offer so far so
i have decided to choose the same
charity again
hadley dementia action alliance and
officially add
hadley guides and scouts i would welcome
ideas as to how i can help to raise
funds for these organizations
during the current climate
so thank you all for inviting me to be
your chairman for a second term
it seems likely that i'll be spending
much of it behind this screen
but i will continue to do my best to
represent the council
to the best of my ability
now we'll move on to the rest of the
meeting
and we move on now to the election
of vice chairman of the council
may i have nominations for vice chairman
do i have a proposal and a secondary
police
chairman yes i'd like to nominate
councillor adrian osborne for vice
chairman of the council
adrian uh as you'll be aware
uh councillor grandin has been a very
able deputy to you
and has served his apprenticeship very
well and i know that
um to succeed you he will be a very good
chairman
next year so i would like to propose
adrian
and call for a second thank you council
award
yes can we have a second to please yes
i'll be very pleased
councillor peter bear here i'll be very
pleased to second the
nomination for councillor adrian osborne
who uh despite his um habits with
cricket
he has certainly given you the time and
support over the last year
and done quite some good things for the
um
district council so i have no doubt in
supporting him
and i hope other members will as well
thank you madam chairman congratulations
to you
thank you councilman on both counts um
thank you are there any further
nominations please
if there are no further nominations i'd
like to ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to take the roll call vote thank you jan
thank you chair um if members can reply
with four against staying thank you very
much
councillor arthi four councillors
four councillor barrett four
councillor beer four councillor busby
four councillor carpendale four
councillor creswell
sorry was councillor creswell there
sorry
no okay councillor davis
cancer dawson for cancer fraser
cancer gould sorry no she's not here
tonight cancer granger howard
four council grandin four councillor
hardacre
councillor hinton councillor holt
four councillor huron
cancer haran are you there
four councillor jameson
four councillor lindsay
councilor malafizi or councillor mabry
abstain councillor mccraw four
councillor mclaren ball councillor
newman
councillor norman four counselling nun
four cancer osborne
councillor jan osborne four
councillor councillor owen
four cancer parker paul
councillor plum four council award
four okay chair that is carried
i declare councillor adrian osborne duly
elected
congratulations um i'd like to invite
the oh well i'd like to invite the vice
chairman to sign the declaration
um of acceptance of office but i think
you'll be doing that on a
another day i'll read my uh
i'll meet i'll read the uh the
declaration thank you councillor osborne
um hit i hereby declare
uh i adrian osborne hereby declare
that i take the office upon myself and
will julie
and faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
i undertake to be guided by the suffolk
local guide
code of conduct in the performance of my
functions in that office
and i would just like to first of all
congratulate to you catherine uh on
being re-elected to chair of baber
i wish you a very successful year
as you've uh portrayed in your and your
acceptance speech
i'd also like to thank my proposer john
ward
and uh second peter bear
and all the councillors for putting
their trust in me
to be your vice chairman catherine
i will give you all the support you
require i will also be a strong
ambassador for our council and our
communities
before i close i would also like to
thank our governance team
and civic office team for their support
and hard work
thank you madam chairman
thank you to our vice chair
we'll now move on to um apologies for
absence
uh jan thank you chair if members could
please reply present when i call your
name
i have received apologies from
councillor gould and
we think councillor creswell but um if
there any more please can you um
let me know now or i will do the roll
call thank you
okay cancer arthy present cancer is
present counselor barrett present
counselor beer present counselor busby
present counselor carpendale president
councillor creswell
[Music]
fraser present councillor granger howard
president councillor grandin president
councillor hardaker
president councillor hinton president
councillor holt
cancer halt are you there
[Applause]
okay we will um try to get councillor
haran
president councillor jameson president
councillor lindsay president
councilman malvizi president councillor
mayberry
present councillor mccraw present
councillor mclaren present councillor
newman
president councilman norman president
councillor nunn president councillor
adrian osborne
president councillor jan osborne
president
councillor allison owen present
councillor parker
thank you
thank you um we'll now move on to item
four
declaration of interest by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
[Music]
so there are no declarations of interest
thank you
we'll move on to item five paper bc
21 to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 21st of july
2020 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
could i have a proposal please chairman
can i will propose it
i will propose it but i think councillor
holt has rejoined us
i've seen it come up on my screen
thank you councillor i have noticed it
um councillor
presents thank you
so thank you councillor beer um you're
proposing could i have a seconder please
councillor jan osborne i'm happy to
second the medal chairman
thank you councillor osborne um
the corporate manager governance and
civic office will now take a roll call
vote
for the minutes to confirm the minutes
thank you
thank you chair if you can reply with
four against or abstain
counsellor arthy for cancer heirs
four councillor barrett four councillor
beer
four councillor busby walt
councillor carpendale council davis
at bought cancer dawson
paul can you hear me yes i can cancer
fraser
for dr granger howard
lindsay councillor malveazy
that was councillor lindsay sorry thank
you councillor mayberry
for councillor mccraw for
councillor mclaren for councillor newman
four cancer norman
four cancer nun four
councillor adrian osborne
four cancer jan osborne
four councillor owen
four councillor parker four
councillor plum four council awards
four thank you chair that is carried
thank you the minutes have been approved
the mints of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed
at the next practicable opportunity
item 6 bc 22
announcements from the chairman and
leader
i refer you to paper bc 22 for noting
thank you council ward do you have
anything to report
i do chair thank you
thank you 2020 has been a strange and
difficult year
and it looks like we're not in the clear
yet with further local lockdowns around
the country and nationwide restrictions
there is definitely a second wave coming
but we don't know to what extent we will
be affected here in suffolk
and what measures we may have to apply
over and above those that the government
has mandated
we are fortunate in having had only 296
confirmed cases of covert 19 and baba
although this is much less than the true
number as many cases have gone
unreported
but sadly 59 deaths the curved 19 rule
of six is in place
but don't forget the stick with it
suffolk campaign which highlights what
we must all continue doing to keep each
other safe
and ultimately to defeat the virus the
impact of covert 19 has been felt by
many businesses around the county and we
have seen many
adapt by changing the way they operate
and support their customers
you will have received an email from
councillor halt last week informing you
that baba wants to recognize those
businesses
as well as celebrate those who put
innovation at the heart of what they do
and to this end we are holding a virtual
innovations award event on 3rd of
november
and we are now inviting nominations for
11 categories
so just as an additional reminder if you
know of any businesses who you think
should be considered peace please feel
free to nominate them or encourage
businesses to enter themselves
the closing date for nominations is
sunday 27th september
we are continuing to monitor the
financial impact of government on our
finances
and the first quarter financial
monitoring report was debated by cabinet
earlier this month
our budget for 2020 to 2021 will be
affected significantly by covert related
costs and income losses
however we have had substantial support
from the government
and whilst our reserves are not large
and we will have to use some of them
we will be fine this year the
medium-term prospect however was
difficult before this
and has now got worse finally on a latin
note
we had a low-key royal visit a couple of
weeks ago in my award when the princess
royal visited the shelley center for
therapeutic riding
where she is the president so you'll see
normal life
is continuing as much as possible thank
you chair
thank you council award
um item 7 designation of committees and
joint
committees we're now going to appoint
the following committees
and joint committees babe overview and
scrutiny committee
planning committee weber licensing and
regulatory committee
joint audit and standards committee and
the joint
appointments committee could i have a
proposal to appoint all the committees
listed on the agenda
i propose chairman thank you council
award
i may have a second please i'm happy
second madam chairman it's councillor
jan osborne
thank you councillor osborne um
the corporate manager governance and
civic office will now take a roll call
vote
again members if you could respond with
four against or abstain
cancer arthy four councillors
four councillor barrett four
councillor beer four councillor busby
four councillor carpendale four
councillor davis councillor dawson
four councillor fraser paul
councillor granger howard
four councillor granton four
councillor hardacre councillor hinton
bob cancer holt
councillor huron councillor jameson
paul councillor lindsey
councillor malveazy for
councillor mayberry for councillor
mccraw
for councillor mclaren for
councillor newman for councillor norman
four councillor nunn or
counselor adrian osborne
or cancer jan osborne for
counsellor alison owen or councillor
parker
or cancer plumber
and council award
thank you chair that is carried
[Music]
thank you uh that is carried
thank you there's going to be a lot more
votes like this this evening
um item 8 bc 23
political balance and composition of
committees
i would like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce paper bc23
thank you chair i would like to present
the report which is the political
balance and composition of committees
in recommendation 2.1 the council is
asked to agree the political balance and
allocation of
seats as detailed in appendix a
the council will note that the overall
political balance has changed
due to councillors rejoining the
conservative group
in recommendation 2.2 the council is
asked to agree the appointment
of committee members as per appendix b
which is included in the tabled papers
pack
there has been a late alteration to this
appendix
which has been circulated to members and
that change is that councillor ayers is
to be appointed to the licensing and
regulatory committee
instead of councillor fraser chair i'm
happy to answer any questions on this
paper and would seek a proposer and
seconder for the recommendations
thank you um
so could i are there any questions first
of all
oh second of all sorry i i need to seek
a
proposal and second of first and then
we'll move on to questions
um john ward are you um offering to be
a proposer i am madam chairman
yes i'd like to propose the uh the
competition with committees as as
presented independence b
thank you council award may have a
seconder please
thank you councillor osborne
have we got any questions uh to put to
our monitoring officer regarding this
paper
councillor mabry have you got a question
um well it's a comment uh more that
i never received the email
ah okay um
which are monitoring officers would you
is there any comment you'd like to make
in reply to that
j if i can just clarify if it was the
email with the late papers
the most up-to-date version is also
included in the modern.gov
app so all members can access that
document
but the only change was the one i've
just described which is
councillor airs being added to the
licensing and regulatory committee
rather than council of fraser
thank you does that answer i think that
solves your
your situation you have all the
information you require in that case
counselor maybe
um thank you thank you chair actually i
don't because modern.gov
is not working where i come currently am
thank you are there any other
any are there any further questions
regarding this paper
if not we'll move on to the vote
in that okay so there are no further
questions
can we move on to the vote please i'll
ask the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to now take the roll call vote thank you
thank you chair again if councillors can
reply for or against or abstain
counsellor arty four councillors
or councillor barrett councillor beer
four councillor busby councillor
carpendale
four councillor davis or councillor
dawson
councillor fraser for
councillor granger howard
councillor grandin four councillor
heartache
[Music]
cancer hinton
[Music]
councillor halt or
cancer or councillor jameson
councillor lindsey
councilman malveezy four councillor
maybach
mayberry for councilman mccall
councillor mclaren
councillor newman four councillor norman
four councillor none
counsellor none
four councillor adrian osborne
four councillor
jan osborne councillor owen
four councillor parker four
councillor plum four council award
four thank you chair that's carried
thank you um that vote is carried
thank you could i just ask counsellors
to
mute their speakers um
if they're not speaking
that we're getting quite a lot of
feedback so if you wouldn't mind just
meeting when you're not
uh in the process of speaking that'll be
helpful thank you
item nine election of cares and vice
chairs of committee
so we're going to elect a care and vice
chair for the following committees
and joint committees weber overview and
scrutiny committee
planning committee weber licensing
and regulatory committee joint
audit and standards committee joint
appointments committee
it is my intention to take the
nominations as tabled
for the overview and scrutiny committee
the joint order and standards committee
and joint appointments committee i will
then take nominations for the chairs and
vice chairs
of planning and licences and regulatory
committees
individually could i have a proposal
for the table nominations please
hey what do you mean
i need someone to propose i'll propose
chairman
thank you is that sue carpendale thank
you thank you councillor carpendale
dave busby dave busby thank you
councillor busby
are there any further nominations
for those appointments
for those three committees
in that case though there are no further
nominations
we'll proceed to the vote the corporate
manager governance and civic office
will now take a roll call for those
three committees
thank you so chair just to clarify we
are voting for nominations for the
chairs and vice chairs for overview and
scrutiny committee
uh audit joint order and standards
committee and joint appointments
committee only
at this point okay so if i can have four
against or abstain
counsellor arthy
cancer beer did you want to say
something
[Music]
yes thank you pardon do we do we need to
know the names of the
chairmans and vice chairmans of those
three committees they're in your table
to pack
um i haven't got that particular one but
i'm assuming they're the same
they're exactly the same thank you okay
thank you so if we can go to the vote
counselor arthi for councillor ayers
or councillor barrett or
councillor beer for councillor busby
four and they were on the email or sent
out of 436
yes councillor carpendale or
councillor davis or councillor dawson
paul councillor fraser for
councillor granger howard
[Music]
paul councillor grandin four
councillor hardacre four councillor
hinton
or councillor holt or
councillor haran or councillor jamison
or councillor lindsay
[Music]
councillor malveezy or councillor mabry
for councilman mccraw or
councillor mccarran or councillor newman
or councillor norman four
councillor none four councillor adrian
osborne
or councillor jan osborne for
councillor owen for cancer parker
four councillor plum war
council award four
that vote was carried thank you
so we'll now move on to the next two
um committees may have nominations
for the chair of planning committee
please
yes can i propose that um
peter beer uh is the chair of planning
thank you that councillor barrett it is
yes thank you
thank you councillor barrett may i have
a seconder please
madam chairman i'd like to second please
counsellor malveezy
thank you councillor malveezy for
seconding
are there any further nominations please
uh yes chairman councillor alfie here
i'd like to propose stephen plum
um stephen has been on committee since
2015
um and has been an excellent vice
chairman since
may of last year um i wanted to say a
little bit
more about reasoning here though um
and it's now over nine years
since council beer was first elected as
chairman um
of what was then called development
committee apart from a
short period in 2017-18 i think
he has held the position continuously
in may of last year after the elections
council of beer was returned to the
chair unopposed
but i did make it clear at that meeting
that i thought this year would be the
time
for a change and that change
was that stephen plum the current vice
chairman would
step up to the chairmanship i think
stephen is an excellent choice
he would be a steady and reliable
chairman in a difficult period both for
planning policy
and for decision making and i have great
pleasure in proposing
stephen for the chairmanship of planning
committee
madam chairman on a point of order i
think councillor
arfy i was opposed last year
thank you bye um
by yourselves and um i won it by one
vote
thank you
may seek a secondary now to um second
the proposal for councillor plum please
madam chairman councillor john hinton
here yes i'd like to
uh second that nomination for council
stephen planford
vice chairman of development committee
uh i agree with all that uh councillor
arthur has said there has been
a long period under councillor beer and
i think the time is right for a change
having been a past chairman of uh
i know that it needs a refresh every so
often
uh and i think the last year's
performance has shown that we do need
that uh
clarity uh and i'm sure it would also
prevent any potential conflicts
with council of beers other function
which of course is chair but planning at
county
all right they just look after their own
properties when it comes to planning but
they do have an impact on
what's happening in communities and i
think the time is right for us to have a
change
and i think stephen plum would make a
very good chairman of planning
madam chairman again sorry in a point of
order but councillor hinton has got that
wrong
i am no longer chairman of suffolk
county council planning
because i prefer to stay on baby thank
you
thank you are there any further
nominations
just to point chair this isn't a a point
of anything but clarification i think
counselor miss
clatzler hinton misspoke slightly in his
uh nomination
he's referred to stephen plum as a
nomination for
vice chair and this of course is for
chair
thank you for pointing that out
councillor mccraw thank you
thank you councillor macron my apologies
there to councillor plum
very easily done thank you
are there any further nominations
madam chairman chair council award
council ward um are you wanting to say
something yeah
just just a couple of things um
i understand what uh councillor arthi
has said about
wanting a change but we are in a
particularly challenging time for
determining planning applications
um as a result of the delay in our joint
local plan
um and and also we've got potential
changes to the current planning system
uh coming up from central government the
consequential impact
uh that these things may have for
applications in the
in the next year could could be
significant and we do really need to
make sure that the committee decisions
are based on a sound understanding of
policy
and that they will be defendable should
appeals be lodged against them
so we really do need someone who's
experienced and can manage and direct
and steer the committee during what will
inevitably be
some difficult decisions in the next few
months
and and i don't think that now is the
time to
to make a change at the top we need that
continuity we need that experience
and and that's why i think that council
councillor beer
would would be the right person to stay
in this position
at this moment in time thank you
thank you council award so this isn't a
matter of for debate
this is a matter that we are now going
to move to a vote
it is a matter of um making our choice
now
and so um when it's
not open for debate we've had our
proposal in secondary
and i've given council award the
opportunity to speak
but we'd now i'd now like to move on to
the vote
so the corporate manager for governance
and civic office
will now take a roll call vote um
for the role of chair of planning
committee
thank you so councillors if you could
reply with the name of the counsellor
you wish to vote for
councillor arthi plum
airs counselor peter beer
councillor barrett councillor peter beer
councillor peter beer yes
peter beer councillor busby
stephen plum cancer carpendale
councillor beer councillor davis
councillor stephen plum cancer dawson
yeah cancer fraser
[Music]
peter beer councillor granger howard
councillor peter beer councillor grandin
councillor plum cancer hardacre
plum councilor hinton
plum councillor holt
peter beer councillor haron
councillor peter beer councillor mccraw
councillor stephen plum councillor
mclaren
councillor peter beer councillor newman
[Music]
councillor peter beer cancer norman
councillor peter beer councillor none
counselor plum cancer adrian osborne
councillor beer councillor jan osborne
councillor peter beer councillor owen
councillor plum councillor parker
councillor plum councillor plum plum
council awards councillor peter beer
okay i'll just tally up the voting and
um we'll let you know the result shortly
thank you
16.
thank you everybody councillor beer has
been elected
1614
so councillor beer is duly appointed
chair of planning committee
may i have nominations for the vice care
of planning committee
please could i have a proposal oh
yes can i have nominations first and a
proposer
for vice chair
is that councillor glenn osborne yes
thank you madam
chairman i'd like to propose mark newman
as chair of the licensing committee
thank you
oh no we're still on the vice chair of
our apologies
sorry i'm a headliner
vice chair of planning committee that
we'll be voting on next
uh councillors could i
goodbye oh is that councillor hinton
no it's councillor mccraw oh councilman
crawl thank you
uh since we're uh apparently going to
keep continuity i'd like to propose
councillor stephen plum
as vice chair of the planning committee
thank you council mccraw can i have a
seconder please for
thank you councillor hinton so
are there any further nominations please
in that case if then john
osborne have you still got your hand up
for have you got a further nomination
oh thank you um so now we'll move on to
the vote then if there are no further
nominations for vice care of planning
the corporate manager governance and
civic office will now take a roll call
for vice chair of planning
thank you chair if you could reply for
against or abstain
counsellor arthy four transfer heirs
four councillor barrett four
councillor beer
oh sorry i pressed the wrong way four
councillor busby
four councillor carpendale four
councillor davis four cancer dawson
or cancer fraser poor
cancer granger howard cancer grandin
four councillor hardacre
or councillor hinton or
councillor holt
cancer holt are you voting
okay we're going to councillor huron or
cancer jameson or councillor lindsay
council lindsay port councillor malveezy
or councillor mabry for
councillor mccraw for councillor mclaren
councillor newman for council norman
four councillor nunn four
councillor adrian osborne oh councillor
jan osborne
for councillor owen
four councilor parker four
councillor plum four council awards
four thank you
thank you councillor plum
is newly appointed vice chair of
planning committee
thank you
yeah may have nominations for the chair
of
licensing and regulatory committee
please
councillor john osborne thank you madam
chairman i think i'm on the right path
you are indeed i'd like to nominate
councillor mark newman he's done an
admirable job over the last few years
and he will continue to do so so i would
like to propose him with confidence
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor osborne may i have
a seconder please
i will second
thank you councillor carpendale thank
you i'll take your um
voter secondary please are there any
further nominations please
are there any further nominations
in that case if there are no further
nominations i think
um do we still need to go to a vote
right okay yes we still do have to go to
a vote
so um in that case we only have one
nomination
and that's councillor mark newman and i
will call
on the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to take the roll call vote thank you
thank you um chair if members can reply
for against or of stay
counselor arthi four councillors
four councillor barrett four councillor
beer
four councillor busby cancer carpendale
four cancer davis four cancer dawson
or cancer fraser four
councillor granger howard cancer grandin
four cancer heartache
four councillor hinton
councillor holt okay
councillor huron what council jamison
four councillor lindsey
councillor or councilman mabry
against councilman crawl
counselor mclaren paul councillor newman
or councillor norman four
answer none four councillor adrian
osborne
or answer jan osborne four
councillor owen four councillor parker
poor councillor plum four
and council award four
so that vote is carried so i declare
that councillor newman
is duly appointed as the chair of
licensing committee
thank you may i have nominations for the
vice chair
of licensing and regulatory committee
please
so councillor brynn horan are you
nominating
your hand seems to be up yes madam
chairman i would have great pleasure in
nominating
councillor sue carpendale she's been
doing the role for a time and
is um extremely competent
and i know wishes to continue so i have
pleasure in um nominating councillor
carpendale
thank you thank you councillor harren
may i have a second
please yes i'll be mr um
second uh councillor sue carpenter
that's councillor beer is it
yes thank you thank you councillor beer
so we have a proposal and a second are
there any further nominations
please for vice chair of licensing
and regulatory committee
if there are no further nominations um
we'll pro we'll proceed straight on to
the
vote the corporate manager
governance and civic office will now
take a roll call vote
thank you thank you chair if members can
reply for against her of staying
cancer arthy four cancer heirs
four answer barrett paul cancer beer
four councillor busby four
cancer carpendale four councillor davis
port cancer dawson paul
councillor fraser four councillor
granger howard
paul councillor brandon
four cancer heartache
that's a hard acre are you with us four
okay cancer hinton or cancer heroin
for cancer jamison
or councillor lindsey
councillor malveezy or councillor
mayberry
for councillor mccraw four
councilman karen councillor newman
or councillor norman
four councillor nunn four
councillor adrian osborne four
councillor jan osborne
four chancellor owen paul
councillor parker paul councillor plum
paul a council award four
that vote is carried so i declare that
councillor carpendale
is duly appointed as the vice chair of
licensing committee
and i'd like to congratulate everyone
who has successfully
uh become chair and vice chair of their
respective committees well done everyone
thank you
i'm sure you'll do an excellent job
now we'll move on to item 10
paper bc 24
appointments to outside bodies for the
years 2020 to 21.
i refer you to appendix a in the tabled
pack
i would like to invite the leader to
introduce paper bc
24 and move the recommendation
in the report council award
thank you madam chairman yes i'd like to
present the paper bc
24 to council this evening um
this is to consider all of the
appointments to the various outside
bodies
that um we are represented on um the
appendix a contains all of the uh
various nominations that there are no
changes from
last year uh these are the nominations
that we agreed
in 20 uh the um uh council meeting
annual council meeting may 2019
uh there are no need to change and
everyone's been doing a great job in
their respective committees
so i'd like to propose a recommendation
in this report
that these councillors as illicit
independence a are appointed to outside
bodies for the forthcoming year
thank you council award may i have a
seconder please
come for arthur yes i'll second that
thank you
thank you councillor arthi so now we'll
um
move to a roll call vote and i'll ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to take the roll call vote on this
oh counselor fraser did you want to say
something
you have your hand up uh yes madam
chairman um
i don't know whether i need to uh report
a
uh an interest here but i'm the armed
forces covenant
uh champion for suffolk i'm not just
counseling hinton's there so i thought
i'd better declare that just to make
sure
thank you i'll speak to our monitoring
officer
that's fine thank you
so oh counselor maybe have you got your
hand up
uh yes um it's not normal practice
madam chairman but um if we need to
declare interests i need to declare that
i am a director of
sudbury citizens advice
thank you councillor mabry that's been
noted
has anyone else got anything that they
need to
say oh councillor osborne councillor
john osborne
yes thank you madam chairman yeah
councillor maybe has reminded me as well
i always tend to forget to do this i am
also a trustee of the cab so i declare
that as an interest
thank you very much thank you councillor
osborne nated
i'll be ready to move on to the vote
in that case if we're ready to move on
to the vote
i'd like to ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to take the
roll call vote
thank you thank you chair if members can
respond with or against or abstain
cancer arthy four cancer heirs
four cancer barrett four
cancer beer four councillor busby
four councillor carpendale paul
councillor davis or hanson dawson
cool cancer fraser four
councillor granger howard
councillor grandin four that's a hard
acre
four councillor hinton what council halt
well sorry he has left the meeting
councillor haran or
cancer jameson for councillor lindsay
councillor malvesey for councilman mabry
councillor mabry
okay councilman mccall councilman
mclaren
for councillor newman for
council norman
parker paul councillor plum
fall council award four
thank you i think councilman maybe has
dropped out of the meeting
thank you that vote was carried
so we'll move on now to item 11
appointment of councillors to the shared
revenues and partnership
joint committee the nominations have
been tabled
could i have a proposal please
yes i'll propose thank you council award
i may have a secondary please
yes i'll second to council
so i think we can move straight to the
vote on this
um the corporate manager governance and
civic office
will now take the roll call vote thank
you
thank you chair if members again can
respond before against or abstain
cancer arthy
that's the carpendale
cancer carpendale
okay councillor davis or cancer dawson
councillor fraser or cancer granger
howard
four cancer grandin four
cancer heart acre
council hinton what cancer haran
what cancer jamison or
councillor lindsay councillor melviezi
or councillor mayberry
i think we've lost councillor maybe
councillor mccraw four
councillor mclaren ball councillor
newman
four councillor norman four
councillor none or counselor osborne
adrian osborne four councillor jan
osborne
four councillor owen four
councillor parker four councillor plum
four council awards
four
thank you everyone that vote is carried
so now we'll move on to item 12
appointments to the suffolk joint
standards board
the nominations have been tabled
could i have a proposal please
yeah i'll propose them dave busby dave
bosby thank you councillor busby
i may have a second to please
that counts them all easy
councilman feces
yes sorry i was still on mute
i'll second them please thank you
councilman
easy so we now have a proposal and
seconder i don't think we need to go for
a
discussion on this i think we can go
straight to the vote
um the corporate manager governance and
civic office
will now take a roll call vote
oh council councillor carpendale is
there anything you wanted to say
sorry you've got your hand up um sorry
sorry chair that my internet's fooling
around
uh oh no no problem
happens to us all i can touch again now
fine
thank you carpenter uh councillor
carpendale so in that case we'll move on
to
the roll call vote i'll ask the
corporate manager government specific
office
to take your vote thank you thank you
chair
again if members could respond with four
against or abstain
counsellor arthy councillors
or councillor barrett
councillor barrett i can see you're here
sorry four councillor beer
four councillor busby
answer carpendale or councillor davis
or cancer dawson paul councillor fraser
four councillor granger howard four
councillor grandin
four councillor hardacre
four councillor hinton what counselor
harren
cancer jameson for counsellor lindsay
four councillor malfeasy for
councillor mayberry i think we've lost
cancer mayberry
councillor mccraw for councillor mclaren
for chancellor newman four
councillor norman four councillor none
four councillor adrian osborne paul
councillor jan osborne for
councillor allison owen paul
councillor lee parker paul councillor
stephen plum
four council awards four
thank you everyone that that vote was
carried
i will now move on to item 13
appointments to the joint gypsy and
traveller
steering group council is asked to point
four councillors to the joint gypsy and
travellers steering group
the nominations have been tabled please
may have a proposal
exact uh councillor jameson yeah i'll
propose chair happy suppose
thank you councillor jameson i'm happy
to talk to madam chair
and who's that please adrian osborne
thank you councillor osborne so i think
we can move straight to the vote again
on this one
so um the corporate manager governance
and civic office
will now take a roll call vote thank you
thank you chair if members again could
respond with for or against or abstain
counsellor rc for
davis
councillor davis
okay councillor dawson for councillor
fraser
or councillor granger howard or
councillor grandin four cancer hardacre
paul councillor hinton or councillor
harren
or councillor jameson
for councillor lindsay
councillor malveezy for counselor mabry
councillor mccraw four council mclaren
for councillor newman or
councillor norman four councillor nunn
or councillor adrian osborne four
councillor jan osborne four
thank you
thank you everyone that vote was carried
now we're moving on to item 14
appointments to council working groups
councillors asked to appoint councillors
to the following working groups
as tabled community community
governance review working group
constitution working group
member learning and development working
group
and the local plan working group
can i have a proposal please
i'll propose madame chairman thank you
is that council award
it is thank you and is that councilman
easy it is madam chairman i would like
to
second the proposal thank you council
malveezy
so unless anyone has anything to say
we could um proceed to the vote
for everyone's happy to do that
fine in that case we can move straight
to the vote
thank you chair cancellers if you can
respond with for or against or abstain
again
counsellor arthy four cancer heirs
four councillor barrett four
councillor beer four councillor busby
four councillor carpentale four
councillor davis four cancer dawson
paul councillor fraser four
councillor granger howard four
councillor grandin
cancer hardacre
[Music]
lindsay
councillor malveezy for councillor
mccraw
four councillor mclaren four
councillor newman four councillor norman
four councillor nunn four councillor
adrian osborne
four councillor jan osborne four
councillor owen four councillor parker
four councillor plum four and council
awards
four
thank you that's that vote is carried
so now move again on to item 15
bc 25
extension to the appointment of the
independent persons
for code of conduct complaints
i would like to invite emily you'll our
monitoring officer
to introduce paper bc25
thank you emily thank you chair i would
like to present
the report which seeks the council's
approval to extend
the appointment of the independent
persons for a further two years
the independent persons were jointly
recruited by baba and mid-suffolk
district councils
ipswich borough council and suffolk
county council in 2018
for a two-year period with the option to
extend for a further two years
the borough and county councils have
already agreed the extension of the
appointments
and we have all been very impressed with
the high quality of advice received from
the independent persons
please could i ask for a proposal and a
seconder for the recommendations
and again i'm very happy to answer any
questions chair thank you
thank you could i have a proposal is
that
um council malveezy
thank you very much madam chairman i
would like to propose
um the three persons nominated
thank you thank you councillor arty are
you seconding
yeah i'll happily second that they carry
on for another two years
thank you now i am able to offer this up
for
questions and debate um
if there is if there are no questions
and no one which is to
debate we can move straight on to the
vote
but i am able to offer it for questions
and debate
if so wished madame councillor hinton
yeah a quick question if i may yes
and that is that uh we're extending this
for a further two periods what's the
workload been like in the previous two
years we don't seem to have had a report
on uh activity of the monitoring
committee we usually we
used to get one saying how many cases
there had been and uh
and so forth and so on from there but we
don't seem to have had any monitoring
report on that we seem to have a lot of
these committees nowadays
but don't hear a lot about what they're
actually doing thank you i'll put this
to our monitoring officer
emily can you help us please thank you
uh chair yes
councillor hinton's right we do uh
generally bring a quarterly report to
the joint audit and standards committee
uh meeting to report on the number of
code of conduct complaints that have
been received
however because of the agenda items that
were already planned for those
committees
and because of the committee having a
period of
not meeting due to the initial stages of
covid
it just hasn't been possible to bring
forward that report
uh in terms of the actual volumes of of
complaints
they are still steadily coming in
so we are receiving code of conduct
complaints uh
typically um around
five a month i would say is the current
uh sort of volume
but the independent persons don't
necessarily
get asked to comment on every single
complaint
some of them are dealt with by myself or
my deputy monitoring officers
at first filter and we only refer it on
to the independent person if it's a
particularly complex case and we want to
take initial advice
or if we are about to determine whether
or not the code has actually been
breached
so if the uh criteria of it being
classed as a code of conduct complaint
is met and we go down that formal
process
at that point we are required to consult
with the independent persons
so they wouldn't deal with all of the
complaints that come in
um but there certainly is enough work to
uh justify having three independent
persons to
to deal with it thank you chair chair if
i could just have a follow-up on
that uh five five a month that
sounds like quite a lot but presumably
that's spread across
all three levels of local government
parish district and county
um is there a rough sort of proportion
as to how that comes in
um emily could you answer that please
yes joe of course
um so as district monitoring officer i'm
responsible for complaints about
district councillors and
town and parish councillors within the
district so uh county council complaints
happily are directed to the uh county
monitoring officer
um the spread of work predominantly i
would say complaints
are from the town and district at sorry
town and parish
council level thank you
thank you are there any further
questions or
are there any further questions
would you like to open this debate or
shall we move straight to the vote
in that case straight to the vote fine
i'll move this straight to the vote
thank you for
that um the corporate manager government
specific office
will now take the roll call vote
thank you chair if councillors again can
respond with four against or abstain
cancer arty for cancer heirs
or cancer fraser four
council granger howard
cancer grandin four councillor hardacre
four cancer hinton what
cancer haran or cancer jameson
for counselor lindsey
councillor malveezy for councillor
mccraw
moore councillor mclaren paul
councillor newman four councillor norman
four councilman nunn four councillor
adrian osborne
four councillor jan osborne four
councillor owen paul cancer parker
paul councillor plum and council awards
or thank you
that vote's carried so thank you
everyone for that
and so that now completes the
appointments aspect of this evening's
meeting
so thank you very much for uh your
participation
and patience and i'd now like to move on
to
item 16 recommendations from committees
paper 16 a item 16a
jac 19 1924
annual treasury management report
2019-20
i would like to invite councillor huron
to move the recommendation
on the agenda councillor horan
thank you very much madam chairman it's
my pleasure to do so
um this is the joint treasury management
management out turn report
for 1920
this covers the position for the out
term for the financial year
just concluded it provides details of
the performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period
and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management policy
the report report explains in more
detail the factors affecting the
strategy
and activities including the regulatory
framework
economic conditions interest rate and
liquidity risk
towards the end of last year the spread
of the coronavirus began to change
life as we know it covert 19 which had
first appeared in china in december
19 started spreading across the globe
causing plumbing plummeting sentiment
and falls in financial markets
not since the global financial crisis
interest rates which had remained steady
during the year at three quarters of a
percent
were reduced by the bank of england to
one quarter of a percent in march
and then swiftly following another
reduction to a record low
of .01 percent that's one tenth of one
percent
at that time the uk government
introduced a number of measures to help
businesses and households
impacted by the series of ever
tightening social
restrictions culminating in pretty much
the entire lockdown of the uk
more specifically for weber regarding
banking
activities the council operated within
the daily bank account limits
we've increased our short term debt by
nine and a half
million this was to take advantage of
lower interest rates
following the increase in the public
works loan board rates
the council led a further 4.1 million to
cifco
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty lists
the council's investment activities
including average returns
can be found at appendix c of the report
madam chairman the council made another
investment of two million
in a higher yielding strategic pooled
fund
investec diversified income fund
investment in funding circle has reduced
as
unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid
that amounted to 216k of the 430
borrowed
or invested sorry leaving the balance as
the
31st of march as the remaining 214k
the council is compliant with the upper
limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the year was done so
in priority order of security and
liquidity over yield
as prescribed in the treasury management
strategy
members should note that in
recommendation 3x3 it should read the
treasury management activity
for 1920 and not 1819
as printed i think somebody was trying
to catch me out there chairman
but i have pleasure in um proposing the
report
and look for a second uh i'll answer
questions if i can but i understand the
melissa evans
and also catherine steele are in
attendance for the complicated ones
thank you i've enjoyed my year and a
half and look forward to um
carrying on as you've given me confident
confidence too
for the rest of the year thank you thank
you councillor unfortunately
councillor grandin has um temporarily
had a frozen screen so we're going to
need to
adjourn the meeting for 10 minutes okay
and so if we can adjourn for 10 minutes
and come back at
19 30 1915
thank you
everyone back now feel refreshed and my
computer is feeling refreshed now
so um resolved the
the issue um
so we'll resume the meeting now
and um sorry for the interruption
councillor huron
thank you for your presentation
councillor haran
and may we have a secondary
i'll second madam chairman thank you
councillor ward
so now we can open it up to questions
and debate
counsellors may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and it must be a question when we get to
the debate element
counselors will only be allowed to speak
once
for three minutes and this will be timed
so would anyone like to open up to the
open up the questions please
have you no questions in that case if we
have no questions
and no debate we could move straight on
to the vote if everyone's happy to do
that
yep so for content we'll move on we'll
move straight on to the vote
the corporate manager governance and
civic office will now take a roll call
oh
sorry councillor mccraw did you want to
say something
i just thought that it was a matter of
importance that we make it plain
uh to anybody viewing this scheme
um either live or later that this report
has received the full attention of audit
and standards in a very lengthy session
on the subject uh so councillors may be
satisfied as must the public be that
this has received proper consideration
thank you very much council mccraw for
that very valid point
thank you is there anything else that
anyone would like to add
so if there's nothing else we'll move on
now to the vote
if everyone's content to do that
thank you so i'll call on the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to take the roll call vote thank you
thank you chair if cancers can respond
with four or against or abstain
counsellor arthy four cancer heirs
four councillor barrett four
councillor beer four councillor busby
paul cancer carpendale four
councillor davis moore cancer dawson
cancer fraser four councillor granger
howard
four cancer grandin four
cancer heartache
lindsay malveezy
for councillor mccraw four
councillor mclaren for councillor newman
four councillor norman four
councillor nun four counts
cancer adrian osborne four councillor
jan
osborne four councillor owen
paul councillor parker four
councillor plum or council awards
four
thank you that vote is carried thank you
item 17 on our agenda
bc 26 overview and scrutiny committee
work
plan 2020 to 21.
i would like to invite council mccraw to
introduce his report
which is for noting councilman crawl
thank you very much chair um this won't
take very long
the report is in front of you and
describes the work plan for overview and
scrutiny
for the rest of this council year if you
refer to your papers
you can see it presented in front of you
our work plan was interrupted by kovid
19 but
was amongst the first of the committees
to go back into full session
and in many months we've actually been
doubling up on our meetings
proceeding with two a month and uh a lot
of this of course has been carried out
in uh
joint session with the mid suffolk
overview and scrutiny committee
so the work plan is there i'm happy to
take any questions on the remaining
business
for the rest of this year and for the
future work plan
in in the year to come after that you
will note that we
have canceled the october meeting and
that was basically
a matter of scheduling and bringing
reports together at the right time
but in compensation for that we've
brought other items forward
uh by bringing meetings together at the
uh
on a two-month basis so this is a a
welcome break for a hard-working
committee
thank you council mccraw has anyone got
any questions
to put council macro regarding overview
and scrutiny committee work
plan
adrian osborne um i think you have uh
you've got your hand up there
hey thank you madam chairman it's not a
question as such but i'd just like to
compliment alastair for his
hard work throughout the year on on this
and the time that i've been
with him he's been an excellent chair
and got the
uh over and scrutiny really uh really
buzzing
and whatever he lost during the parts of
covid
he certainly caught up with thank you
and i would certainly agree with that so
yes i fully support what you've just
said
council award
yes i was going to say the same thing
actually the overview and scrutiny
committee
does have a very heavy workload they
look at a wide range of the council's
business
and they they do go into a lot of detail
when um looking at things and they come
up with some very good
recommendations to to cabinet and
council so um
uh and alistair has done an excellent
job he he's certainly
um as as the years have gone by i know
he's been in the role now for for quite
some time but as
as time goes by he he is certainly
getting
very very experienced at this and
as an asset to our council quite
honestly um
i think uh it's most recently
demonstrated in
in the work that they have done looking
at our
capital um investment company cifco
because uh it has uh been controversial
uh it's had its critics
um but overview and scrutiny has played
a such a huge role in making sure
that uh sifko is is performing well for
the benefit
of not just this council but for all of
our residents and the services we
provide to them
so i need to thank alisa and the rest of
the committee
thank you council award councillor davis
yeah i just want to add to to what has
been said previously but
uh and also giving mention for
councillor osborne because
again he's one of the the sort of powers
behind the throne if you like
you know and he he's done an excellent
job um as as has
overview and scrutiny and uh led by
councilman mccraw so
well done to you guys and more power to
your elbow keeping us
cabinet and others in check
thank you councillor davis councillor
busby
thank you chair i appreciate the work
that you you guys are doing but i know
i'll stay you'll be twitchy throughout
the whole of october without a meeting
to
to attend and share therefore i'd like
to
suggest that perhaps if you haven't got
anything on plan
you could look at the effectiveness of
joint meetings between baber and mid
suffolk particularly
cabinet briefings and cabinet meetings
and the audit
and standards committee
okay to address that point if i may
counsel a busby um as a member of joint
audit and standards uh i found that that
actually hasn't been
a major problem since so many of the
factors
uh are in common and it is even more
true
at overview and scrutiny now we work
very closely with the mid suffolk
uh committee and more often than not we
meet in joint session
there are obvious occasions matters of
the budget and the housing revenue
account
uh obviously are reserved for each
individual council
uh the practical matter of organizing
meetings of the cabinet
and organizing joint meetings is
probably outside our purview
we can observe by our own
working methods all i can say is that
from a personal point of view
working in overview and scrutiny and
audit and standards
it has not been the problem that i think
it may be
perceived to be uh in cabinet and
obviously we've never met in full
council but i know in cabinet it can
lead to
lengthy meetings
probably not our job to say what
cabinets should do though
[Laughter]
we can make recommendations to cabinets
but under the
final analysis it's the cabinet's
decision
you've completed your questioning
counselor busby thank you
um councillor john osborne
thank you madam chairman um i'd also
like to concur with councillor osborne
council
award and councillor davis on their
comments about the chairing of alistair
he is an excellent chair
and i have to say it's really reassuring
to have him at the helm when
scrutinizing the work being undertaken
by housing
i attend those meetings on every
occasion and
there's been lots of items that have
been scrutinized
um over the last 12 months and as i say
it is reassuring to have him at the helm
so
thank you very much councillor macron
i'm just hoping you can get through your
front door in the morning with all these
compliments but thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor osborne councillor
davis your hand is still
raised did you want to say something
further
it is an old hand but i will um support
what counselor busby said
and and i think there's a bigger issue
because about the office of time
with all these joint cabinets whether
it's an effective use
i know some may suspect that just
lumping everyone in together is but
uh it's also a counsellor time and a lot
of us don't just do counsel we have
other things as well
so i i think it is worthwhile the over
view and scrutiny looking at
it and i think it is within their remit
to look on the on a wider scale on that
so i'm disagreeing with council mcgraw
here okay
thank you councillor davis is there
anything else you'd like to say
councillor mccraw
really just to say that it's not the
first time councillor davies and i have
disagreed on certain matters of
procedure
um it's a this subject is a matter of
constant discussion
at all the chairs meetings for o and s
um
i wouldn't like to be one to suggest how
the two cabinets should approach it i
think that must be
a cabinet decision but all i wanted to
do was i mean whilst
everybody's congratulating everybody
else it's really marvelous my head will
get through the door
but actually i think the main point i'd
make is i'd like to thank the committee
members of both councils
who've served on scrutiny members who've
attended
and most of all two other groups the
officers not least committee services
but all the departments because scrutiny
deals with virtually every
single part of the council at some time
or another
and finally the cabinet who have been
involved and have been responsive to the
work of the committee
attending meetings taking an interest a
lot of this
stuff is done in the sort of a hard
graft in working out what we want to see
in a report and that requires the
support of officers as well as the
cabinet so thank you to all those people
thank you councilman mccraw um arthur
i i think our key executive had
something he wanted to say
arthur did you still want to say
something
uh thank you sherman now that the
moment's passed so there's no problem at
all
thank you did anyone else have anything
they wish to add
otherwise um yes
yes just a quick one i did mention
earlier on in the proceedings about
the monitoring to the report on
standards and referrals to standards um
we seem to be missing quite a few of
these reports and the annual monitoring
report for planning applications etc
which normally comes out in may stroke
june
is still conspicuous by its absence now
i know we've got
covered restrictions which are causing
certain problems in certain aspects
but when it's a question of just
collecting data together it does seem a
little bit strange that we haven't had
that and perhaps uh
overview and scrutiny would like to look
at all the reports that are due
and to try and come up with some sort of
time scale perhaps when uh members
cannot
expect mccraw would you like to reply on
this okay
in both those cases i think i can um
first of all
uh overview and scrutiny have no
responsibility
or remit to look at planning matters
that is definitely
100 outside the remit and those matters
are dealt with through the planning
committee
uh who'd also deal with the planning
charter and
we are always very mindful of the fact
we do not want to
duplicate the work of other bodies and
then the case of the
standards reports happen to serve on
audit and standards
and that is the job of the audit and
standards committee and we're not going
to duplicate
their work either there's enough on our
plate frankly
as it is if everything that was dealt
with
was put on the plate of overview and
scrutiny we would never be able to
prioritize our work
so we're very careful about how we
choose and how we prepare these work
plans they are
a constant working evolution and they
are constantly shifting but we do keep
busy
and we can't really get much busier
my own chairman if i could just come
back on that i appreciate that but
perhaps then
it's something that council award and
the members of cabinet would like to
look at in their
uh relevant departments to find out how
they can
make sure these reports are produced in
a in a timely fashion
tom barker um i see your hand is raised
um uh yes would you like to come in here
thank you if possible i just wanted to
clarify a matter around the
annual monitoring report um
that report has been published in
september for the last couple of years
um there have been extra steps imposed
upon us in terms of public consultation
as part of the creation of that document
and the five year house and land supply
position statements that are associated
with it
and we anticipate that that will be
published imminently
thank you is there anything else that
anyone else would like to
oh counselor rc
um yeah um just really
to say that we've all been busy
acknowledging councillor mccraw's
great work and i agree with all of the
comments that have been made
but it did make me think um that none of
us said anything to bring about all of
the good work that he's been doing on
committee
orders and standards so it's just really
a retrospective thank you to brynn
for all of his good work thank you bryn
thank you councillor arthy i think
that's a good point to bring up
reid your work is well
well done and well deserved um
compliment there
thank you madam chairman and to
councillorati as well
yes we're a bit unsung on um orderton
standards
but we do work hard and um it's
it it's quite exciting as i've said
before it's not exactly sex and drugs
and role but almost so
um it's pretty good thank you thank you
for the kind comments
well deserved thank you anything else
anyone would like to
um say before we move on
thank you well in that case um
that paper was for noting and so you'll
be pleased to know we won't be voting on
that one
and we'll move on to item 18
bc 27 changes to the current planning
system consultation
i'd like to invite councillor arthy
to introduce paper bc 27
and to move the recommendation in the
report councillor arthy
thank you chairman yes you were you will
all have seen paper
bc 27 and noted the four main changes
that are proposed
in the consultation they're outlined at
paragraph 1.3
and they're explaining that paragraphs
4.2 to 422
and our draft responses to the
consultation questions are attached to
the paper
they follow a detailed cross council
cross
party discussion which was held on the
10th of september
the draft responses which i'm proposing
to you this evening
expressed concerns regarding all four
main proposals
and these are clear in the draft
responses but particularly we have
serious concerns regarding the changes
to the standard method for assessing
housing need
which if implemented could see labour's
numbers
rise from 416 dwellings per year
across the planned period to nearly
niner to nearly 800.
i'm sure i don't need to explain the
implications for our local plan
our communities and our rural landscape
but i feel i should also highlight the
potential impact
on our housing land supply position
this report that i've just done for you
is is a a brief one i
did prepare a much longer one but we've
been going quite a long while this
evening
so i'm happy to answer any questions
we've got tom
tom barker here who helped draw together
the group's
expressed views so if there's anything
detailed i'll direct it towards
tom but just to repeat the
recommendation
is the responses that are drafted in
your
in your papers thank you and i'm
proposing them
thank you councillor arthy could i have
a seconder
please councillor hinton
thank you madam chairman um i'm quite
happy to
uh to second uh the uh responses to the
to the questions that have been
being proposed uh i think that clive
arthy and his
um fellow conspirators if i can call
them that
have done a an absolute marvelous job of
trying to
wade through the mire that is that uh
the changing
uh in planning a regulations document
because it's not the easiest thing to
follow because it's full of
contradictions and anomalies
uh when you consider that it says that
for instance on page 11 that
planning decisions are discretionary
decisions
we were always taught when i first
joined the council and went on planning
training that we were a semi
uh litigious uh body that
uh passed legally binding decisions
but they weren't discretionary decisions
with we're not saying to somebody
yes you can do it if you want to but we
rather you didn't
they get a clear yet or no um so that's
one anomaly that immediately jumped out
at me
also that they there's nothing in the
document
that proposes any changes to building
regulations which of course
is the one part of construction
that dictates the method of construction
of houses the size of rooms
the insulation required the
green initiatives that are impo involved
all these things
uh are controlled by building rigs and
if central government don't lay down
firm building ranks to go with this a
lot of their objectives in this document
are a complete another waste of paper
but i won't go on anymore because i've
got a whole page of bits and pieces here
that i've picked out from this document
but just to say well done to clive and
his team for coming up with something
that
at least is reasonably sensible
thank you council hinton i'm sure
there's going to be a lot of questions
and debate
now councillors are asked to comment on
the proposed response
and if there are any amendments to this
response
councillors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject
under discussion and must be a question
when we move to debate councils will
only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
but we'll start with questions uh has
anyone got any questions
um counselor heartache you've had your
hand up for a while
um is that a question that you have yes
question
thank you would you like to proceed
yes um i've read through this um
incredibly long
um consultation and the uh proposed
responses to it and the only response um
i think i have
probably have a problem with and
therefore a question is the response to
question seven
um where we're disagreeing with the idea
of having
a height of being able to place height
restrictions
because i think the obvious probably for
that is if we've got a site and we said
we want
a hundred homes on this site that we
don't want someone to build a hundred
story tower
and so i suppose my question is why are
we objecting to that
councillor arty would you like to answer
that um yeah i'd i'll tell you what i
will do
i'll pass that one um over
um to tom simply because
um it was tom who put together
all of the responses um for
us so he did that as a result of the
cross-party
meeting that we had um and so there were
a few comments about this but i just
wondered if
tom can explain how he put those
together to form our response
tom can you um give your reply please
yes councillor i think that um that this
might actually be
question 26 um that's the only place
that i can find the reference to
to height it's not not question seven i
don't think
although happy to be corrected and look
at that further
27 27 uh sorry
um so essentially this
is because um if you read the answer to
26 they're all talking about the
permission and principle
regime and the approach to permission in
principle and
the the sense of the um cross party
working group was that commit permission
in principle
um just doesn't really work and the
constraints that they're seeking to put
on it
um doesn't really work and the
um limiting of of heights
is something that just it's a it's a
blunt tool essentially
um and it's much better to look at
things on their own basis there could be
instances where
um a taller building actually works
within a street scene or a landscape
and to put some uh blanket restriction
on it
um just didn't really didn't really work
so i'm
happy to take a further conversation
about permission in principle
and its implications outside the meeting
if that would be helpful
um but in essence it was it was that the
planning application process is better
and anything that that suggests
uniformity
could compromise good design
thank you has anyone else got any
other questions
any further questions or would like me
to open this up to debate now
yes please fine so
um was that counselor lindsay
oh councillor ward sorry council award
um
is there anything you wanted to say
first or should we just open it up to
debate
i i would go straight into the debate
actually if that's exactly right yeah
um can we move into debate then yeah
um what i wanted to to say was i was a
member of the um
the group that looked at that uh looked
at this this uh document
um and uh we had a
thorough going through all of the
questions uh and all of the points on
each of the four proposals and there was
surprising and and quite gratifying
unanimity
uh across all of the members from from
both councils
um it is clear that this
these these proposed changes do have uh
i think everyone has serious concerns
not just in this council or mid-suffolk
but
um the the the comments i'm getting
from councils all around the country
everyone has serious problems with
each of these uh proposals here because
quite frankly the the main aim of this
is to increase the number of houses
delivered
that's a loadable aim uh it's clearly a
housing shortage
but these proposals are not going to
achieve that
not at all certainly the the biggest
uh issue with us and i think with
councils everywhere
is the uh the increase in the numbers of
housing we have to deliver the change to
the standard methodology
it's because of the additional
affordability
factor that that's been brought into
this and and the fact that we and baba
have
uh a big affordability problem that
means that our numbers
are going up from the 416 that will be
our joint local plan to
789
the affordability here as everyone knows
is determined more by average wages than
anything else
and this is going to have no impact on
that whatsoever and indeed there's
very little evidence that 789 houses
could actually be delivered here by
any of our developers both both large
medium or small
we are already building and delivering a
good number of houses
the the 2018 to 2019 figure i think was
um
579 which is the best year we've had
trying to improve on that is going to be
very difficult
even in our five-year housing lab supply
calculations
we we base uh currently basing those on
uh 2 900 being the the
deliverable number per year now that
works out at
um 580 a year
still a couple of hundred short of the
718 89.
it's just a target that i don't believe
and i don't think anyone believes
is achievable or based on any kind of
reality within within the district
and you've got to remember what you have
30 seconds
finally we have 4 652 outstanding
planning permissions
we are delivering on our side of the
bargain
by passing planning applications we just
need the developers to build them
thank you thank you council award
councillor john osborne
thank you madam chairman um first of all
i'd like to say that i
that the work that the group and
officers have done in a very short
period of time to put this response
together
is really good so they need to be
commended on that
i have serious concerns about all four
proposals
one that specifically concerns me is the
intention
to raise the threshold from 10 to 45 or
50
before it generates an affordable
housing element you know we're
struggling now to deliver
an affordable housing quota and this
will make it even more difficult to
deliver on that
and i think i i like the response and i
appreciate the response that the group
have put together
i just hope that common sense prevails
on this one
we already see sites being delivered
um with dwellings under 10 to try and
escape the affordable housing element
how many applications do we get that are
between the 45 and 50
and i have a real concern that
developers will pick up on this they
certainly will
and that they'll be developing on
smaller sites they'll be doing piecemeal
sites so they'll do one of 40
and then a few months later they'll come
forward with another one
so that they're um not able to
um they're preventing for them being
able to give the affordable housing
element
so i really hope that the government
take heed on this one as all the four
the three other concerns but this one in
particular and they do change their mind
on it
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor osborne
councillor lindsay
thank you chair um yes
um well i as um council award
said there was i was on the on the
committee that
um working group that looked at this and
we were all pretty unanimous and i agree
with much of what
john ward said um about um
about the fact that basically this is
what the government's trying to do here
is
i mean i don't actually agree that we
have a housing crisis we have an
affordability crisis
we have the wrong we have houses that
are too expensive we don't have enough
that are that are genuinely affordable
but what the government's trying to do
is
say if we build lots more private
housing we'll suddenly get affordability
and uh we won't really do that unless we
concrete over the
entire um every field in baby um
because some of the reasons council
award is outlined
um but but particularly because
developers will only build if they can
make a profit out of it
and so they're not going to make houses
cheaper just because they're given
permission to build more um
so i'm particularly pleased with the
response number four which
says um you know the government is
saying can we artificially boost the
quota
that we have um so we can build more
houses and and get more affordability
and actually it's that's not going to
meet need at all
what would meat need is if we started
building
some of our own houses and had a proper
program
and a proper strategy to acquire land
and to build
our own houses which is why i brought
forward the motion at our last
for council to do that it's not enough
to rely on the private sector to deliver
affordability
it's not enough to rely on a piecemeal
approach
where we go and beg a developer when
they put an offering forward
to have a proportion of affordables we
need to have a proper strategy
to build our own as many other councils
doing around the country
thank you thank you councillor lindsay
councilman crore
sorry chair i had trouble getting my
buttons to work there
uh i'd like to state that i fully
support this response it's
very complete i've looked at both the
questions
and the answers we've provided not only
for this but
the answers i suspect will be providing
for the planning for the future
consultation which uh operates in tandem
with these proposals
and looking through everything the first
thing i notice is that uh
apart from a few minor technical details
where we say yes
in large part we just something object
and we're giving specific reasons
why we object and the question i or the
conclusion i've drawn from this
whole floatation
of a uh of a concept in planning
is who benefits it's not the homeowners
or the people who need the starter homes
that are much lauded
well the only thing i can say there is
that every time a starter home system
has been um
much loaded and promoted it's been a
complete and utter failure
and sometimes at some expense the only
people benefiting in that case were in
fact many of the developers
it also has a knock-on effect because it
will directly affect
our provision of affordable housing no
matter what we think
of that particular definition it is at
least a step that we know
can be delivered do the communities
benefit from this
no because they're going to see the
depth and breadth and the time
of their own consultation responses to
be much reduced
do we the local authorities benefit
local planning authorities are not the
bottleneck in the shortfall or a
perceived shortfall in planning supply
we are acting responsibly uh is the
economy going to benefit well
maybe in the last 10 years we've noticed
that the government's plans uh for
targets for
housing building across the country are
yet to be met once
increasing the target doesn't seem to be
likely to uh
provide any further results
now the only people who seem to benefit
are the development industry
and they've been the principal
beneficiaries of uh
all the planning changes made since nppf
was introduced in
2011 and nppf2 just last year
they maintain uh the matter of supply
not ourselves if the bottleneck lies
there so the whole
concept is a flawed one it's all built
up
series of false premises and i'm glad to
hear that the administration along with
many other administrations and i know
many mps are taking a very very dim view
of this it transfers
the need from inner cities to
rural areas like ourselves um
interesting to note that the
beneficiaries um i don't normally make
political points
in this instance in this instance the
who benefits well the contributors of
the political parties
are available on the electoral
commission website and i'm glad to hear
that we're going to encourage the
government to change their mind
we know they can because they've done it
before
thank you councilman councillor bosby
yeah sorry just to mention to robert um
baby growth
does have a target of building our own
houses uh it may not
be coming forward as fast as i would
like and perhaps not in the number that
i would like but
we will be addressing that in the near
future
thank you councillor busby councilman
easy
thank you madam chairman i just want to
confirm what counselor must be said is
that um
we do have plans to build and to acquire
our own social housing so
just wanted to clarify that position
thank you
thank you i'll be coming
back to councillor arthy um at the end
to sum up but is there anyone
else who would like to um
discuss anything further now jim and
rather than sum up
could i just um follow up councillor
hardaca's
question
okay yes okay i asked tom to explain how
he pulled our thoughts together
regarding
pips and height parameters but i wasn't
sure if councillor hardaker
agrees with our expressed concerns um
in the answer to question 27 or not
would you like to come back on that
um well i mean it's
difficult to formulate i agree i agree
with the general turn of for example
question 26 that it's an objection
i just think i just thought it was odd i
guess that no one said
this cap nothing can be taller than five
stories for example
you know uh well can i
come back i mean that the response to
that question at 27
was to do with um a height parameter and
our concerns were that if you have
um planning in principle and you set a
maximum height parameter what you will
probably do in terms of the development
is that you will allow the whole
development to be built to that height
um so what we're saying um is that if
you look at the
the response um it would compromise
opportunities for good design and visual
interest
um through variation so in other words
you know buildings of different heights
um and and we say in there that the
preferred approach would be to allow
consideration
of height at a technical stage um so
that those issues
are resolved taking into account um
design
um at that stage so i i'm thinking
that councillor hardacre probably agrees
with the response
thank you um can we move on to
council davis please
thank you chair yeah no um i think it's
fantastic that
we have so much agreement um among the
parties because
as has been pointed out you know baby
growth
has and is identifying sites we
recognize that the best way
to to meet these targets that have been
imposed upon us
is to build our own because then we
choose the type
of buildings and homes that people we
know
in this district need so i think it's
fantastic that
um yeah all parties agree that we need
to do this
you know robert's absolutely right we
need to build more social housing
and we as a council can do that we just
need to be
more proactive in doing that and uh and
it's almost a bit of a hobson's choice
the government are telling us
we have to build these homes we can't
rely on the developers
we know quite often they land bank
they've got permissions
um some of the permissions haven't
really
met with the policies that they should
have done but that's
planet committee decisions so we need to
make sure that
when developers do come forward they
need to
adhere to what we want in our district
that's pretty much it
council davis have you got any um
background
noise on if if you um come back and
speak at a later stage
if you could kindly um turn your
background
uh noise off please uh you can hear the
dots can you
i don't know what i can hear but some
things are ringing in our ears at the
moment
thank you um
councillor hinton have you got something
you'd like to say
yeah just just a quick point i agree
with
just about everything that's been said
by the various contributors so far
especially what aleister has been saying
and i would just
say to the leader of the council and to
those who of a conservative persuasion
who support the
the current government just next time
you're speaking to anybody in authority
in the government
ask them to remember the localism act
that they passed in 2011 which was
supposed to give power to local
authorities and they've done everything
since then
mppf's one and two included and this
document
to try and take that power away from
local authorities
thank you councillor hinton are there
any other further comments
um or debate please
if there's no more debate um
may i ask um councillor arthy to sum up
if you'd like to please
um well i think i'll to just run through
what the recommendation is but before i
do that
there was mention of the round table
discussion and
i ought to thank uh councillors ward
busby
lindsay and cresswell as long as cu
as well as colleagues from mid-suffolk
who attended those discussions
and as somebody has said already there
was broad agreement
on the key areas of the consultation
and the response provided i think has
captured those main points
so thank you to all of the people
involved just to remind you that i'm
proposing the recommendations
at paragraph 3.1 and 3.2
which is that we respond to the changes
to the planning system consultation
and that the assistant director for
sustainable communities
in collaboration with the cabinet
members for planning
um consider any proposed amendments to
the suggested response
and be authorized to make amendments
before submitting the response to the
government
so that's the um that's the proposal i
don't think we had a second earlier on
did we
did you have a second day yes it was me
yes john hinton yes we did john hinton
i did no thank you yes so
thank you for that councillor rc so we'd
now like
to um vote on this response
um so if we can move again to a roll
call
vote um i'll ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to now take the roll call vote
thank you thank you chair if councillors
can again send four against or abstain
cancer arthy four cancer heirs
four cancer barrett four cancer beer
four councillor busby four
cancer carpenter or cancer davis
or cancer dawson or
cancer fraser four cancer granger howard
four cancer grandin four
lindsay councillor malveezy
four councilman crawl four councillor
mclaren
or councillor newman
councillor newman
okay counselor norman four
councillor none
counselor none okay councillor adrian
osborne
four cancer jan osborne four
councillor owen
four councillor parker four
councillor plum four council awards
four
thank you that vote is carried
we'll move now to item 19 on our paper
the white paper planning for the future
i would like to invite councillor arthy
to introduce this item
and move the tabled recommendation
counselor
councillor
thank you chairman yes um i know it's
getting
quite late in the evening um and i tried
to shorten
my previous um report and i'll try and
shorten this a bit but
um to be honest with you it will be a
little bit longer i'm afraid
um as i'm sure everybody knows the
government is consulting on a new
planning white paper called
planning for the future and the
consultation closes on the 29th of
october 2020.
the consultation proposes significant
reforms of the planning system to
streamline
and streamline and modernize the
planning process
bring a new focus to design and
sustainability
improve the system of developer
contributions to infrastructure
and ensure more land is available for
development where it is needed
in responding to the consultation there
are a series of questions to be answered
not unlike the previous consultation
that we've just done just
spoken about the item is on the agenda
today without an accompanying report
the white paper is a significant
document and it was not possible to go
through the same approach as the
previous consultation
within the time available
okay the consultation doesn't finish
until the end of october
so we have a little bit more time to
draft our response
but we don't have another council
meeting to bring that to so i am
suggesting the following recommendation
to delegate authority to the assistant
director for sustainable communities
to submit a response to the consultation
on the white paper
planning for the future on behalf of the
council
and that should be done in consultation
with the cabinet member for planning
and the same cross-party group that
considered the changes to the current
planning system consultation
you will uh as i say you would have seen
the the document
it stretches to about 84 pages
but in brief the headline proposals
suggest
several things that i wanted to point
out to you and just highlight
the first of those is zoning
and that will be through a new
stripped-back local plan
with all land zones for either growth
renewal or protection and i'm sure that
that sort of highlight element of it is
something that
that you've all taken notice of
the other bits that i ought to point out
um there's a little bit in
about section 106 coming to an end
um with all contributions being via a
levy
um similar to our existing sill
there's a bit in about top-down housing
targets
um in a similar way to the proposals in
the consultation we've just dealt with
um that is again
something of well we haven't met yet but
that's something i'm sure
um will be of concern to us um
just moving on there's a a new body
proposed with the role of supporting
local authorities in the creation of
local design codes
and each local authority would be
expected to employ a new statutory role
of chief
officer for design and placemaking to
oversee quality
local design codes must have community
input to be
valid there's a bit about
more permitted development in the
proposals
and that would be via the introduction
of
new and more extensive pd rights
that i think has has probably covered
some of the main issues
um that you'll be aware of and that
we'll be discussing
hopefully it sets out those main themes
but i welcome any questions or debate
to help inform the proposed round table
so that's to inform the discussion which
i'm proposing
should take place with the same group as
before
[Music]
and um finally i
i think i said this at the beginning um
but i would i would just go through the
recommendation which is to
delegate authority to the assistant
director for sustainable communities
to submit a response to the consultation
on the white paper
planning for the future on behalf of the
council
in consultation with the cabinet member
for planning as myself
and the same cross-party group that
considered the changes to the current
planning system consultation
that's my proposal thank you
thank you councillor uh may i have a
second
please yes i'd like to second
madam chairman thank you council award
thank you um i'd like to open this up to
questions
and debate we'll move now
to questions and debate counselors can
ask questions
but can only debate the tabled
recommendation
i'll open it up for questions now
would anyone like to start the questions
if there are no questions we'll move on
to the debate
would anyone like to open up the debate
please
councillor busby
actually was just a question when uh
when does clive propose that
we meet again
counselor rc um
i wish you hadn't asked that question
because i haven't got the
oh i haven't got the date with me um but
it's quite soon
oh good
that's nicely answered um councillor
mccraw
thank you chair um everything i said
before on the previous
response still applies um so just to
summarize
this has been my summer reading project
okay all of it and some
associated matters it's based on false
premises
it's a bad piece of analysis it proposes
radical changes without sufficient
supporting
evidence and it's the wrong questions
the wrong set of answers
and it's definitely the wrong time to be
tearing up our planning system
so i hope that's all born in mind when
we submit our response
so i support this uh proposal
thank you councilman crore would anyone
else like to
add to the debate
council mulveezy
thank you madam chairman um it's max of
putting the cart in front of the horse
because we've got the environment bill
coming through which will impact
on planning and how we proceed um
we have a government that says they have
a green agenda so we've got to look at
that
and it just smacks of putting the cart
in front of the horse
i think it's a shocking piece of work
but there we go
thank you thank you thank you councilman
the council award
um it's not all bad to be honest um
there is merit in in a zoning system
provided it's implemented correctly it
is done in many other countries around
the world
um and other aspects the emphasis on
design
um i think we we should all welcome
um particularly if we get that right um
because
we we all complain about many aspects of
design
of new houses and and new developments
not just
size but um uh the fact that
it doesn't take into account uh as much
as we would like uh
the local environment and and um uh the
local standards
um and there's no imagination
in in current design so if we can get
design done better then then i think
that will be a great help
and lastly the other thing that it's
proposing to speed up the the local plan
making process
i think has some merit as well so we
need to look
uh closely at at how it's is proposing
to do that
and see rather than um uh
dismiss it entirely whether there are
any improvements we can suggest
um to that so i think uh unlike the
previous
uh consultation that we just debated um
which
i can't see any merit in that whatsoever
uh there are things in this that um
we can work with and and um and and try
to improve upon so
i'm looking forward to a good few
sessions over the next few weeks and
coming up with
with a measured and a constructive
response
thank you thank you council ward well we
seem to have veered off
the debate on the table recommendation
so unless then anyone would like to add
anything
regarding the tabled recommendation
i'd like to move on to ask councillor
arthy to sum up
is there anyone who'd like to say
anything regarding the recommendation
please otherwise
counselor arthi please could you sum up
um well before i do that my apologies to
councillor busby i've just been
frantically looking through to see if
i've got any um
the draft dates for for us to get
together
and i'm afraid i can't find those at the
moment so we'll have to come back to you
on that dave
um no i haven't really got anything to
add
to what i've already said um save just
to
um to remind you again um of what the
recommendation is did you want that in
in actual wording or can i just say the
recommendation is the same group as
before cross
party cross council gets together to put
together
our response in a similar way to it to
the one that we did
on the consultation for the current
planning system
thank you that will do nicely um so now
we'll move on to the vote the corporate
manager governance and civic office
will now take a roll call vote thank you
thank you chair for the last time this
evening if members could respond with
four against or abstain
cancer arthy four councillors
cancer barrett four cancer beer
four councillor busby four and i can't
wait
councillor carpendale four councillor
davis
what cancer dawson ball
cancer fraser councillor granger howard
council grandin four councillor hardacre
councillor hinton or councillor haron
four councillor jameson war
councillor lindsay four councillor
melveezy
four councilmember crawl four councillor
mclaren
or councillor newman
sorry no longer here councillor norman
four councillor nunn
so i don't think he's here any anymore
either cancer adrian osborne
four councillor jan osborne four
councillor owen cancer parker
sport plum four
and council awards four thank you
sorry can i just say um thank everybody
for their confidence in the working
group
and i noticed how easy it was to save
for when you're not actually having to
do the work
um could i just say actually dave busby
got in before me because i was going to
say
thank you to everybody for the
confidence they're showing in us thank
you
thank you well just to uh just to
confirm
that vote was carried and
that is the end of the meeting
thank you all for attending this evening
and for all your patients
with the huge number of votes that we
were having to
do as a roll call i believe at the next
meeting
in november on tuesday 24th of november
at 5 30
uh hopefully we'll have the electronic
voting in
in place by then um but thank you very
much for
attending today's annual meeting and
how enjoy the rest of your evening it is
now
13 minutes past eight and
i'd like to close the meeting and thank
you all for attending
you